everyone welcome to gel car we do have a
quorum uh Senator Lang will be here late
he has a car problem
and so we'll see representative hacken
Phillips in for a representative hatch
who will not be here
and congratulations on the senate for uh
the um
the minutes of the last meeting
does anyone have a motion
okay
any additions Corrections or deletions
okay seeing none of those in favor
aye
opposed
okay is there a motion on the consent
agenda
all right moved by Senator Ward we're
seconded by Senator Ennis
those in favor
aye opposed
all right takes care of consent we have
a lot of people
um would director Morrow could you uh
give us a list of the ones that are to
be postponed
yes
they are final proposal
2022-232
MHP 300s
uh from the Board of Medicine
FP
2023-27 physician assistance Med 600.
Board of um
Board of Professional Engineers final
proposal
2023-116 on continued status
from the mechanical licensing board FP
2023-48 on continued status
and let's see final proposal
2023-61 from the real estate appraisers
board continued status
fp2023-103 individual and business
entity licensing
okay
some of those will need waivers but
um
we expect to have all of those at our
next meeting correct yes we do
the waivers are for um
2023-116
2023-48
2023 61.
and
2023-103 okay I moved I moved to
postpone as requested
second okay
all right those in favor
aye opposed
all right that clears out a lot of the
uh
simple stuff
and so we start with the Board of
Medicine
excuse me the Board of Education
yes uh so the Board of Education uh
final proposal
2023-31 on the procedures for approval
of for professional educator preparation
programs
um this one did have a conditional
approval request filed with our office
and it did address the majority of the
comments the only remaining substantive
comments are there is one on page two of
the rule text it's an unclear comment
due to the wording of the sentence
and the comment did propose some
language that would clarify the
requirements in order to make that
sentence clear so if the board was
willing to change that that would take
care of that comment and the other one
is just an informational note to the
committee this proposal
got rid of
um repealed quite a number of sections
because there were redundant
requirements in these uh 600s and the
500 so a lot of the language was
repealed and the other proposal that is
renumbering the 500s is actually just
approved on the consent agenda 2023-22
so the citations that are in this
proposal reflect that renumbering in
good morning Steve Appleby Auburn New
Hampshire director at Department of
Education we would take the suggestion
or the State Board would take the
suggestion made by OLS regarding the
wording and file a conditional approval
for for conditional approval I apologize
so what could happen is the committee
could
um
approve conditionally approve this based
on the conditional approval that was
filed and then
additionally with that change
all right
any questions
I'll make that in motion
okay seconded by Senator Ennis
and discussion
seeing none those in favor
aye opposed
all right thank you very much and uh
that was simple
all right
then the board of Engineers
okay so uh
2023-44 ethical standards and license
surrender engineer 500s
um
I'm not seeing anybody from the oplc
here
um a conditional approval has been filed
there is one unclear editorial on page
four that really could be addressed at
adoption however the main issue with the
proposal is that the rules have been
expired since January of 2022 and so the
committee may have some questions about
enforcement of ethical standards
there is a statute that does require
Engineers to be of good professional
character and that's RSA 310 a13
so the board does have that statute to
enforce but without any rules in place
it's not clear what good professional
character will mean and how they'll
enforce that but I'm not seeing anybody
from the oplc here yeah is there anyone
from the agency
I didn't see anybody either okay we have
a question on how they enforce the
expired rules
um
if I could the um the other proposal
2023-116 is continued status for
engineers so that one's been postponed
you could postpone this item as well and
no all right
does the committee have a any position
on this
no
all right in that case I move we
postponed this one also and deal with it
since that will be before our our
deadline anyway seconds
those in favor I opposed
okay we will uh find out what they're
what the engineers are doing
actually you will need a waiver for that
one I'm sorry to postpone it
is the meeting is on September 21st and
um the deadline's the 19th sorry all
right then yes we will ask for and
change the motion to include asking for
I made my section as well okay
those in favor
aye opposed
thank you and more ethical standards
with the soil scientists
so this proposal has the same issues as
was just discussed these rules have been
expired since March 18 2019
there is a statute that does list some
violations that may be
considered as ethical standards such as
any person who gives false or Forge
evidence to a board in obtaining
certificate would be a violation however
there's a number of other ethical
standards that are not encompassed in
that statute that are in the rules
and also there was a conditional
approval request filed with this
proposal which addressed all the other
issues so that was the only remaining
issue with this but once again it
doesn't seem as there's anyone from oplc
and I take it the next one from the real
estate
appraiser board also has the same issues
that is correct okay we've
Madam chair yes if the committee West we
could wait to take action until further
in the meeting if they show up
what
we will do that on both of them because
I want to find out what they're doing
with not and with their with expired
rules
all right well so we'll skip over the
real estate appraiser board
and
so the professional geologist there was
a conditional approval request filed
however there is still some issues
regarding the rule
um specifically there's an unclear
comment on page one of the rule text
excuse me the conditional approval rule
text
um
that is oh and I apologize I'm going to
back up a little bit there were a number
of comments on this one because we still
did not have a form submitted for this
particular proposal however a form was
submitted so a number of my comments on
the conditional approval request have
been
um
fixed due to that having that form so
the only remain new comment that I have
is um that the rule itself does not have
the title of the form in it it's simply
sites to the PLC 308.06 rule which is
that Universal
application for license renewal form
however that specific rule does not have
the title in it either so with regard to
these geologist rules
the title should really be in there in
order to make it clear which form is
actually being discussed it sounds to me
as though that could be a
conditional approval that could be fixed
fine so does someone wish to make a
motion to conditionally approve these
provided they add in the title of the
form
okay
it's moved by Senator chandley second by
those in favor
aye opposed
all right and I apologize this has
nothing to do with the vote the
committee just took but I just also want
to make the committee aware that on this
proposal and a number of other proposals
that are going to be coming forward from
the professional boards we have been
making informational notes to jail car
about the fee issue just to keep that on
your radar and to also track which
boards are citing to those particular
PLC rules okay
we have plenty of information about
those
Madam chair yes the Department of
Environmental Services is here if you
want to skip ahead to their room
it's item m
M good point because I don't see anybody
from agriculture
unless there is
no in that case let's skip ahead to the
Department of Environmental Services
it's out to the agriculture rule may
take some discussion
all right so this is final proposal
2023-136 the alteration of terrain there
was a conditional approval request file
that did address a majority of our
comments the only remaining comments on
this um proposal is there is an unclear
comment on page 18 of the conditional
approval request text
there were a number of forms submitted
with this particular Rule and one of
them the amendment request form cites in
the certification in just one section
RSA 641 with regard to
the criminal penalties that may come
from
not
signing falsely or misrepresenting any
information in the application instead
of the specific citation RSA 6413 and
this is important because RSA 641 1 is
specifically for penalties of perjury
which
cannot be a criminal penalty unless it
is statutorily in the it's statutorily
authorized to be under the rules
so that comment was made on a couple
other places on this proposal but were
fixed so it seems this one was just an
oversight and in talking with the
Department it seems they are willing to
fix that which can be done
at adoption or in addition to the
condition uh conditional approval
request the other unclear comment is on
page 46 with regard to the appendix
um
we have been informed that department
has a new staff member working on
administrative rules and as the
committee is probably aware
administrative rules is a very steep
learning curve to get into so we are
working with the staff member in order
to make the appendix more clear as this
was not the only proposal this issue had
come up on and we have been told by the
department that the appendix will be
fixed at the adoption stage for this
particular proposal and moving forward
will be fixed
uh finally there was a note to jail car
on page 12 once again regarding that RSA
641 issue the reason this is a note is
because
these rules cite specifically to Environ
Envy WQ
150310 which is not in this proposal but
that rule also broadly cites RSA 641 so
that is just something the committee
needs to be aware of and potentially the
good morning
good morning I'm Courtney Lockwood here
for the Department of Environmental
Services and I am the new staff member
that she's referring to so yes we'll
make those Corrections
I am impressed that you managed to get
the alteration of terrain rules through
without significant public comment so
I'll congratulate you for that
all right
move by Sandra during a second by
representative Schmidt is there any
further discussion
seeing none those in favor
aye those opposed
so
okay
um I don't know if anybody from
agriculture is here
um so this proposal is adopting a single
section in the chapter 700 rules which
have been expired since 2009
um just to be clear it is only one
section in a chapter the chapter 700
that has been expired since 2009. the
rest of the chapter is also expired yes
the title of the chapter well it's on
the acquisition of agricultural land
development rights
um and yes that entire chapter has been
expired since then so this proposal is
just adopting one section
um and you know the section doesn't live
in isolation there are other
requirements in the chapter 700 rules
that should apply when evaluating land
for example the expired section just
before this one
705.01 is about the evaluation of
applications
um
just yeah it's the entire yeah sorry for
um so you know the agency hasn't brought
forward any other sections other than
this one
um so the committee may have some
questions about that
um besides the expiration issue the
proposal cites a form but the agency
hasn't submitted any form to be reviewed
and just a reminder there is a statutory
change that does require the submission
of forms with a final proposal but that
isn't effective yet
so like I said the form hasn't been
submitted and so the committee is being
asked to approve a form that hasn't been
reviewed at all
there's one other issue and you'll see
that on the top of the page page five of
the
of the packet and that's just around
what's an unclear around what does
potential and suitability mean if they
had a definition section then they could
probably Define this but they don't
so those are the main issues with it
there is also a node just you know as an
FYI to the committee that representative
Peter Bixby has submitted an email
stating that from his opinion that the
rules do meet legislative intent so I'm
glad to hear that but beyond that you
know it does have the the issue of the
entire chapter being expired and these
being expired since 2009. yes all right
is there anyone from the Department
nope okay
we're any any comments from the
committee
well
I'm glad that they meet the legislative
intent but I'm seriously worried about
something that's been expired for 14
years
that's a very long time and the rest of
the chapter is still expired and it
doesn't seem to us that they've started
to work on it
no I've not seen any proposals come
forward for it Madam chair yes I I would
say that for I think three months
the department does have a person
dedicated to rulemaking I think she is
part-time but and it's going to take
some time because they have
a higher percentage of rules that are
Madam chair yes I think it's also
concerning that the form they're asking
us to approve has not been presented and
you know I'm wondering
you know where does that put us you know
as a community well we have a couple of
options we can ask for a waiver and
postpone it we can approve it site on
scene which I'm not going to vote for me
neither and or we can oppose the rule
on the make it put in a preliminary
objection on the grounds that we don't
know what's been going on since 2009 and
there's no forms
so do you care to make a motion
the last one okay Senator Ward moves the
preliminary object to the rule
second second by representative Schmidt
any further discussion
no okay
those in favor I opposed
and I would like to thanks
representative Bixby for checking the
new laws and approving making sure the
rule is in the in accordance with it
okay and I will convey your remarks to
representative Bixby who's a fellow
Dover rep okay a good friend of mine so
I appreciate that
all right Broadband matching Grant
initiative
um so they have filed a conditional
approval request and I don't have any
comments on this one because this um the
conditional approval request really did
resolve all the comments that I had
however the interim rules expired last
month on July 4th so there is that issue
and there's been some testimonies
submitted on the proposal and so that's
the reason why this isn't on consent so
I thought what I would do is kind of go
through each of the comments that were
submitted as testimony if that's okay
and then we could have the agency
address them
looks like someone is here so the first
comment you'll see is on page one of the
conditional approval request and that is
around the expiration of the rule down
at the bottom of the page there is a
comment testimony was submitted that the
definitions for underserved locations
and unserved locations and over build
could be a bit more detailed and that
there was some overlap between
underserved and unserved definitions I
took a look at this alongside of the
statute and I thought that the
definitions were you know in line with
the statute whether or not they could be
a bit more clear I do see there is a
little bit of overlap between the two
but um so that was one issue the next
one is on page four of the conditional
approval request at the top of the page
and the testimony here was a really
around the scoring criteria they thought
that the scoring could be more detailed
to address how the agency will determine
whether or not the project will deploy
faster service or otherwise meet the
objectives of the statute
um I think that that's probably going to
be a policy decision and as time goes on
the agency will probably have more to
you know that it could do more and amend
the rules here to um around the scoring
issue they'll probably have more detail
to add later
um the next one is on the very next page
on page five
and here this is on the challenge
process and
um this talks about that the challenging
party shall provide detailed proof that
the application is in violation of the
statute and the testimony really wanted
you know maybe a definition or to
explain what this detailed proof would
be and it to me it seems like the
Challenger should should really submit
everything that they have to prove so I
don't know necessarily the outlining
here everything would be really in the
best interest of the Challenger or the
agency so I didn't place a comment
detail proof could be defined they could
put an example here if you if if that's
something that you think they should do
but um so that was that comment and
there's one more on the next page this
is the last one it's on page six and
here this is about
um well it says failure to provide
timely reporting to the agency will
result in non-compliance of the contract
and testimony wanted something in the
rule stating that there should be notice
and opportunity for a cure
I believe that that's most likely going
to be in the contract that the GNC
approve they could put it here in the
rule they may not need it but but they
might so those are the issues with the
rule
motions
I will say I I called representative
leishman who worked on the legislation
creating these grants and was unable to
actually speak to him
so
we don't have any update on the
Michael was just about decision director
moral you had a comment
um regarding the wish to have notice and
an opportunity for a hearing in other
settings that would be perfectly
appropriate and would be required by law
but if this is done pursuant to a
contract it would be entirely dependent
upon what the contract says
yes yes I agree that that's that sort of
detail is more appropriately covered in
all right do you have a motion senator
okay Senator and this moves to approve
is there a second
okay second by Senator Ward
further discussion
all in favor
opposed
okay thank you very much for us for
showing up
laughs
all right any other uh
I believe the only other business is an
emergency rule that we can um
we should be discussing correct yes but
we still do have some of the uh
boards uh rules that the committee
hasn't dealt with yet either to postpone
or to go ahead and take it haven't they
been postponed
not all of them I think for example 49
from natural scientists right
and 50. I believe we skipped 49 and 50.
that's G and H
please let's postpone them 49 and 50.
we'll need a waiver for 50. okay I move
we postpone
to our next meeting and ask for a waiver
second
any other discussion
those in favor
aye opposed
all right and uh we will remind the oplc
um Madam chair there's also
um the objection response for 20 23.89
on the agenda but I just wanted to let
the committee know we have not yet
received that response they did get a
waiver to extend their deadline to
August 31st so they still have a little
more time to submit that okay well
that's um
that's reasonable if we haven't got it
we don't need to talk about it
so the emergency rule the emergency rule
um is from oplc it's for The Advisory
Board of Respiratory Care practitioners
on May 23rd a regular rule went into
effect
regarding continuing education it was
doubling the hours for continuing
education for Respiratory Care
practitioners Within
two to three weeks the agency had to
have a public hearing because they had a
lot of negative feedback from
licensees and in fact they had a couple
of dozen licensees show up at the
meeting saying that this was going to be
very difficult because they had did not
have notice of this
change until it went into effect while
they may have been legal notice
apparently a lot of licensees didn't
realize it
expiration of the licenses is is at the
end of this year so they would only have
eight months to complete all the the new
doubled requirements
the emergency rule specified several
reasons why this was going to be
problematic for licensees there's a
desperate shortage of them right now so
it's very difficult for the
practitioners to take time off to do the
continuing ad which is routinely during
the daytime there were a couple of other
reasons and oplc said that this was
not only a safety issue because
they were going to have to take time off
to do this it was going to be a shortage
also financial burden on the
Respiratory Care practitioners
themselves by doing the extra they did
indicate too that National associations
were in favor of the lower limits and
the lower limits were pretty much
standardized in other jurisdictions
so the emergency
backed off from their increased uh
continuing education requirements
exactly yes
well it's nice to know that I heard from
a couple of respiratory therapists who
were concerned that the CEO had had
suddenly doubled so it's nice to know
they were listening to the people
involved and I'm not sure where they got
the idea that they needed a whole lot
more continuing education I I don't know
technically
an emergency rule is not completely
necessary because there is probably time
for oplc to go through regular
rulemaking before uh the the licenses
expire at the end of the year but that
sort of leaves the practitioners in
limbo you know if the rule doesn't go
into effect then suddenly they have to
have 24 hours instead of 12 hours
yes and we could always petition
we could petition to withdraw the
emergency room it sounds like the
emergency rule is more sensible than the
rule it's withdrawing so
I don't think we need to take any action
okay unless you do do you think they
need 12 hours no no I I just think it's
kind of a bizarre situation it is
bizarre and what worries me is that the
rule change was not
noticed by the licensees sure any
questionably noticed yeah well then a
bunch of them came back out and said hey
we never heard about this which
apparently is what happened I think we
ought to
what we'll do is request oplc to check
into its notification procedures because
they should have been note been notified
historically a 541a required
um
where the uh there was rules regarding
licensees that there be personal notice
of every single licensee of course this
became burdensome because sending out
mail to say with the Board of Nursing
when you've got tens of thousands of
licensees of course that was before
really email was available and certainly
they must have a list of licensees and
they could use email at this point I I
would think so and perhaps we should
consider reinstating that requirement
because
I mean this is clearly a failure to
communicate and it's something that if
it weren't something that it sounded
like the board was stretching to impose
on the licensees it could have been
something much more urgent
they did use the legal mechanism of
publishing in the register but that
doesn't always get to individual's
effects right exactly
okay
okay oops
all right then do we have any other
business uh just whether or not you want
to
eliminate the continued meeting yes I
would notice that there's a need for it
right I would note that we've postponed
about eight or nine rules today and
we've already received
12 final proposals for next month and we
have two weeks to go uh uh so do you
think we should have the continued
meeting and just for the postponed rules
we could do that it would help eliminate
a huge crush I think at the next meeting
but it's up to the committee okay how
about do you could you guys show up for
another meeting to get rid through all
the oplc stuff right
I believe that's two weeks from today
which is the 30th 30th okay the 31st I
since we have questions on all of them
and what they're doing on their uh
expired rules
doodly noted well perhaps a little
Senator Lang why
we have several yeah I think I think we
should we should plan on that one just
because we've postponed a significant
block of specifically oplc rules the
alternative would be to have a continued
meeting in September uh depending how
many final proposals we do have in
September and how many the committee can
get through I think that since we've got
a nice block of them off of the same
agency with mostly the same issues we
should just do it and get it over with
and uh
yes
hopefully the all of the new proposals
will be on consent one never knows
okay committee has does not have to take
any action because the meeting is
scheduled
are adjourned and we'll see you on the
okay
so